انشقاقات داخليه في الحكومه وغضب شعبي صب
في شوارع اسرائيل محركها الاساسي رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامينه ياهو بما دعا
اليه من تعديلات على النظام القضائي في
البلاد خط الازمه بدا بعد عوده نتنياهو
الى السلطه في يناير 2023
بالتزامن مع فصل المحكمه العليا حليف
نتنياهو من منصبه كوزير للداخليه على
خلفيه قضايا فساد وتهرب ضربي ليكشف وزير
العدل في الحكومه الجديده انذاك عن خطه
اجراء تعديلات على النظام القضائي
خطه اثارت غضب الاف الاسرائيليين كونها
تمنح الكنيسه سلطه اكبر على حساب القضاء
كتعيين القضاه والغاء التدخل المحكمه
العليا في الاوامر التنفيذيه
وتمهد الطريقه وغيره من المسؤولين للحصول
على الحصانه التامه
احتجاجات لم تظهر بالصبغه التقليديه بين
يمين ويسار بل اغلبيه ضد ما سمي الانقلاب
على نظام القضاء
الغضب الشعبي المستمر تزامن مع تحذيرات
الرئيس الاسرائيلي من الانهيار القانوني
والاجتماعي في البلاد بينما ازدادت حراره
النقاش تحت قبه البرلمان
ولربما كي لا يصب نتنياهو الزيت على النار
ارجا التصديق على تلك الاجراءات حتى ابريل
القادم الا ان انتقادات وزير الدفاع
الذي خلقه داخل الحكومه بالاعتراض على
التعديلات كانت السبب في اقالته من قبل
نتنياهو ليكون شراره ثانيه تزيد من حراره
المظاهرات الرافضه في اسرائيل ويصل
الانقسام الى منظومه الجيش ايضا فمئات
الضباط رفضوا الالتحاق بوحداتهم
المعرضه الاسرائيليه حاولت الدخول في
الثغره بين حكومه نتنياهو مطالبه بحجب
الثقه عنها لكن الحكومه نجت من الاقتراح
الا ان التصعيد الاخر كان مطالبا بحل
الكنيسه
الى عمر العربيه